l'association prévention routière se
mobilisent contre la mortalité infantile
sur les routes
la structure vient de lancer un
manifeste aux lignes autour du thème 0
enfants tués sur les routes cette
opération a pour objectif d'enrayer un
phénomène qui tue chaque fois sept
enfants en france un bilan inchangé
depuis dix ans il ya deux grands types
d'accidents pour les enfants évidemment
les enfants en voiture donc victimes
d'accidents de la route pour lesquels
ils sont évidemment strictement pour
rien et deuxièmement les accidents pour
les enfants piétons cyclistes ou
trottinettes rollers etc
un enfant surtout si les petits 4 en
cinq ans il fait pas il n'y a pas de
notion de vitesse de rapprochement et il
fait pas la différence entre une voiture
qui est loin une voiture qui est petit
le manifeste propose cinq mesures une
tva plus faible sur les sièges auto la
mise en place des systèmes anticollision
piétons sur les véhicules limitation de
vitesse à 30 kilomètres/heure autour des
parcs et des écoles
aménagement des passages piétons et une
obligation d'équiper les cartables de
bandes réfléchissantes les mesures déjà
mises en place dans certains pays en
europe
pour ce qui concerne le marquage au sol
des des passages piétons aux états unis
pour ce qui concerne le
l'équipement des véhicules en systèmes
de
d'alert anticollision donc donc ça
existe déjà et ça fonctionne le ballif
est déjà recueilli plus de 3500
signatures le document sera remis aux
pouvoirs publics à l'automne dans les
yvelines un enfant de cinq ans a perdu
la vie en 2015 après avoir été percuté
par une moto